bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des mieux' avec
du vieux alors déjà un paléo news en
janvier parce que il y a eu beaucoup
d'actualité qui sont sortis pendant les
vacances de fin d'année et que vu que
c'est les vacances de fin d'année et
barel sur toutes passées à la trappe
évidemment l'actualité scientifique ça
n'intéresse pas grand monde quand c'est
noël et le nouvel an mais heureusement
et bien je suis là pour vous offrir
cette petite session de rattrapage sur
l'actualité scientifique qui est sortie
et vous allez voir qu'il y avait du
lourd dans les tuyaux et pour commencer
il ya eu et bien un anneau tyrannus d'un
os tyrannus qui a eu un peu qui a eu le
privilège d'être le seul à avoir un
petit peu atteint les médias il ya eu
quelques mêmes qui sont sortis quand
même sur les réseaux sociaux à propos
d'un anneau tyrannus puisque apparemment
ça y est se serait confirmée nano
tyrannus n'est rien d'autre qu'un
juvénile de tyrannosaurus rex
donc c'est ce qui est proposé dans cet
article c'est l'hypothèse qui est
proposé dans cet article paru dans
silent house 26 donc une dessous branche
de la revue science
et cet article déjà vous pouvez voir
qu'il ya du beau monde dans les allées
dans les hauteurs notamment john john
art orne eure qui est mieux connu sous
le nom de jack corner dont bon voilà
c'est au moins une autorité qui se pose
là est donc cet article eh bien il dans
cet article
tous ces braves gens utilisent
l'histologie osseuse donc ils font des
coupes dans des eaux dans des faits murs
ou des humérus de tyrannosaure de
tyrannosaurus rex et de nano tyrannus
pour voir et bien si les tyrannosaurus
rex ce sont des adultes et si les nanos
tyrannus sont des juvéniles et alors
comment on fait ça déjà et bien on
regarde on regarde au niveau des zones
d'arrêt de croissance donc dans l'os il
y à des zones d'arrêt de croissance en
particulier chez les chez les dinosaures
comme chez des tyrannosauridés par
exemple donc vous voyez ces zones
d'arrêt de croissance ici sont marquées
avec des traits bleus est donc chez un
adulte les zones d'arrêt de croissance
en fait elle marque finalement le la
période où l'os a arrêté de grandir et
chez l'adulte donc je disais ces zones
d'arrêt de croissance vont se rapprocher
au fur et à mesure qu'on atteint le bord
de l'os ça veut dire que quand il était
petit l'animal grandi s'est vite et
accumulé donc beaucoup d'os entre chaque
hiver et que au fur et à mesure qu'il
devenait adulte avec certaines
variations évidemment mais en moyenne
plus il devenait adulte et moins il a
cumulé dos parce que bien évidemment il
arrête de grandir donc ça c'est ce qu'on
voit chez l'adulte et chez les juvéniles
bas on voit ça c'est à dire que on
arrive au bord de l'eau ce avec des
zones d'arrêt de croissance qui sont
séparés par de très grands intervalles
de deux très grosses d'épaisseur dos ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup d'os qui
se fabriquait entre chaque saison au
moment où il est mort enfin non ça c'est
pas l'extérieur c'est une milieu mais
voilà ce serait l'idée quoi s'il y'avait
l'extérieur ici eh bien ça voudrait dire
que cet individu est mort jeune parce
qu'il était encore en pleine croissance
il a cumulé encore beaucoup de beaucoup
beaucoup d'os bon là c'est pas le cas
parce que c'est là qu'habite et
médullaires donc c'est le milieu mais
voilà c'est ce à quoi ça ressemblerait
si c'était un juvénile voilà donc on
peut dire en coupant l'os d'un anneau
tyrannus s'il était encore en train de
grandir ou pas et s'il était encore en
train de grandir au moment où il est
mort ça veut dire qu'il ya c'était un
juvénile et ils ont pris donc deux nano
tyrannus de spécimens denanyoh tyrannus
ses deux numéros là
des deux numéros que vous voyez ici qui
ne sont pas d'ailleurs qui ne font pas
partie de la série halo typique de nano
tyrannus donc ce ne sont pas les
spécimens de référence ce sont des
spécimens qui ont été identifiés comme
nano tyrannus et en coupant à
l'intérieur de leur aurait bien ils ont
retrouvé des caractéristiques de
juvéniles et pas des caractéristiques
d'adultes donc voilà nadeau tyrannus en
face c'est denanot tyrannus là au moins
sont des juvéniles ce qui soutient
l'hypothèse que nano tyrannus n'est rien
d'autre qu'un tyrannosaurus rex juvénile
il vivait en même temps au même endroit
voilà il ya un intervalle de forme qu'on
ne connaît pas chez tyrannosaurus rex
donc incertain d'intervalle d'âge qu'on
et bizarrement la nano tyrannus qui
remplirait parfaitement cet intervalle
là si jamais c'était un juvénile de
tyrannosaurus rex donc la coïncidence de
base était déjà trop belle donc il avait
été proposé que nano tyrannus était un
tyrannosaurus rex bas maintenant c'est
maintenant c'est très fortement supporté
par cette nouvelle étude dont qui
suggère la synonymie za sion denanot
tyrannus avec tyrannosaurus rex donc
synonyme isation ça veut dire que nano
tyrannus va disparaître et maintenant on
va les appeler juvénile de tyrannosaurus
rex
alors la sphère n'est pas complètement
pliée quand même puisque comme je les
dis lolo type n'a pas été inclu bon lolo
type il me semble qu'il ya qu' il ya que
du crâne
donc évidemment on peut pas couper dans
du crâne comme ça et puis de toute façon
on verrait pas la même chose ça marche
qu'avec les oslon enfin ça marche
beaucoup mieux avec les oslon le crâne
les modalités de croissance du crâne
sont un peu différentes de celles des os
longs donc ça marcherait pas aussi bien
avec le crâne mais au moins disons qu'il
ya de bonnes raisons maintenant de
croire que nano tyrannus est en fait un
juvénile de tyrannosaurus rex fin de pas
fin de l'histoire mais en tout cas
conclusion qui risque de rester pendant
longtemps voilà ça
il va y avoir du mal à ressusciter nano
tyrannus après ça sachant que comme je
les dis la coïncidence est beaucoup trop
belle donc c'est la fin apparemment
denanot tyrannus est l'une des
implications alors j'attire votre
attention d'ailleurs sur les
implications il ya eu beaucoup de enfin
comme je les dis il ya qu un seul
article qui est passé au dessus du radar
pendant cette saison festive et c'est
celui-là il ya des mêmes qui ont été
faits il ya beaucoup de communication
qui a réussi à être être faite autour de
ce de cet article malgré le fait qu'il
soit sorti pendant la saison des fêtes
mais là où j'aimerais attirer votre
attention c'est sur la véritable
contribution scientifique de cet article
vous voyez ici c'est ce que je viens de
vous expliquer c'est les implications de
leurs études pour l'hypothèse nano
tyrannus donc c'est le paragraphe où il
explique exactement ce que je viens de
vous expliquer qu'en gros nano tyrannus
ce serait du juvénile de tyrannosaure à
part le type ils savent pas encore pour
le type mais bon y'a pas de raison que
le type soit différent des spécimens qui
ont été rapportés donc ça veut dire que
les implications du fait que nano
tyrannus soit à juvénile de tyrannosaure
tiennent dans cette partie de l'article
ici voilà c'est ce paragraphe la sas et
les implications du fait que nano
tyrannus n'existe plus en tant que tak
sont séparés ça c'est la conclusion et
après c'est le matériel méthodes
voilà est ce que ça valait vraiment le
coup que cet article la plus que les
autres soient mis en avant je sais pas
merci la popularité de tyrannosaurus rex
en tout cas voilà parce que vraiment si
la note ira nulle n'avait pas été un
juvénile de tyrannosaurus rex
est-ce qu'on en aurait eu autant quelque
chose à faire je ne sais pas en tout cas
voilà l'implication majeure de ça c'est
que avant on supposait que nano tyrannus
manger autre chose que tyrannosaurus rex
en gros ils remplissaient la niche
écologique des chasseurs de taille
moyenne à petit et maintenant du coup
ben c'est les juvéniles de tyrannosaurus
rex qui était autrefois attribuée à nano
tyrannus qui remplissent ce rôle donc en
fait ça change quasiment rien sachant ça
change quasiment rien à part que cette
partition des niches écologiques qu'on
croyait être entre deux espèces
différentes et maintenant de honte aux
génétique c'est-à-dire qu'elle est
maintenant entre les juvéniles et les
adultes au lieu d'être entre nano
tyrannus etirex voilà c'est tout
c'est tout ce que ça change et ça réduit
le nombre de taxons de tyrannosaurus de
tirano enfin ça réduit le nombre de
taxis ont deux tyrannosauridés dans le
crétacé supérieur à un tyrannosaurus rex
au lieu de deux ce qui peut légèrement
changé les comptes quand il s'agit de
compter combien d'espèces sont mortes
pendant la crise crétacé tertiaire mais
bon voilà ça s'arrête là donc ouais
voilà est-ce que est ce que ça valait
vraiment le coup de faire autant de
bruit pour ça je sais pas c'est bon
c'est pas inintéressant évidemment et
c'était une étude qui était attendue
depuis très longtemps donc voilà ça y
est c'est fait nanou tyrannus c'est fini
mais il y a eu bien plus important que
ça et c'est vraiment dommage que du coup
il est parlé plus de ça dans les médias
est beaucoup moins de l'article que je
vais vous présenter maintenant parce que
cet article là hop je vous montre le
titre cet article là lui par contre il
va changer les trucs lui il va [ __ ] la
merde je n'ai pas peur de le dire je
n'ai pas peur d'être vulgaire parce que
il n'ya rien de trop dans ce que je
viens de dire cet article veut [ __ ] la
merde pendant dix ans ou du moins il va
changer énormément les
les priorités de recherche dans beaucoup
de domaines donc c'est un article qui
s'intitule la phylogénie des amiotte des
premiers à mignotte et les les affinités
phylogénétique départ à reptiles des et
des varannes opiné
c'est paru dans nature écologie et
évolution publié par david ford et
rogers benson tous les deux des anglais
si je ne m'abuse
donc là on est plus en amérique on est
chez les anglais et donc et cet article
et bien déjà le titre parle pour
lui-même quoi c'est une fille laugénie
des premiers amiotte qui nous parle des
affinités de départ un reptile et des
varannes hop idées et pourquoi pas parce
que ils ont fait une nouvelle analyse
phylogénétique des amniotes donc les
amniotes c'est ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement les reptiles du mois quand
on inclut toutes les espèces du permien
du carbonifère et tout ça on appelle ça
vulgairement des reptiles évidemment les
amniotes modernes n'ont pas grand chose
à voir avec les reptiles puisqu'on
inclus on inclut aussi dans les am not
les oiseaux et les mammifères mais voilà
ils ont fait une nouvelle phylogénie
donc de ses amis et de ses premiers
amiotte et donc avec 294 caractère et 70
taxes ont donc c'est plutôt une grosse
analyse alors déjà il ya un truc qu'il
faut dire généralement à propos des
grosses analyse c'est que plus gros veut
pas dire mieux hein ça des fois ça
augmente seulement le ce qu'on appelle
l'omoplate si c'est à dire ça augmente
seulement les chances de trouver des
convergences évolutive donc bon c'est
c'est faut pas non plus croire que parce
qu'il ya plus de caractère une analyse
les plus robustes mais bon elle a au
moins le mérite d'exister cette analyse
et est d'inclure et d'inclure un nombre
de taxes ont assez conséquent tout de
même et donc cette analyse voilà le
résultat ça donne un arbre
phylogénétique donc ici vous avez la
calibration dans le temps vous avez les
espèces vous avez toutes les branches
alors il est assez illisible cet arbre
vu qu'il est énorme
justement c'est le problème aussi
d'avoir un échantillonnage taxonomique
exhaustif c'est que forcément il ya du
monde mais voilà en gros vous avez vous
avez toujours la synchro sein de
séparation des amniotes entre les
synopsis d'un côté et les reptiles de
l'autre alors eux ils choisissent de
parler de reptiles ya au lieu de 100
europe sida je ferai probablement une
vidéo à propos de l' usage de reptiles
ya à la place de sow robes sida je n'ai
pas vraiment de problème avec ça tant
que tant qu'il est très clair
enfin en tant que ce dont on parle est
claire je vois pas le problème
d'employés reptilien mais bref vous avez
donc cette séparation entre les synapses
it c'est à dire la lignée qui va donner
les mammifères d'un côté et les reptiles
c'est à dire la lignée qui donne les
reptiles les oiseaux les tortues les
crocodiles etc de l'autre
donc ça c'est normal par contre à
l'intérieur des reptiles on va trouver
les varane hop idées et les varano pidc
un groupe qui a toujours toujours
toujours été inclus parmi les synapses
ide et ça ça fout la merde
et ça ça fout la merde parce que c'est
pas la première fois qu'ils trouvent ce
résultat déjà benson & company donc il
avait déjà publié deux autres articles
où il suggérait déjà que les varane au
pid et pourraient être des en fait d
et des reptiles des reptiles ya des
sceaux europe side notamment parce que
parce que hors venator maillot rouge or
venator maillot rouge c'est un varane au
pid et il a tout du varane oppidea part
que si on regarde le crâne de oro
venator je crois qu'ils ont une image un
peu plus loin voilà
or venator il est là et vous voyez que
sur son crâne
il y à une fausse temporal basse comme
les synapses it sont censés avoir fait
une fausse temporal haute
alors évidemment il va falloir que je
traduise un peu tout ça parce que c'est
compliqué à comprendre mais en gros
classiquement la séparation entre
reptiles et synap site se fait d'une
façon entre les synopsis ici donc et les
reptiles
ici se fait sur le nombre de fenêtres à
l'arrière de l'orbiteur donc le nombre
de fenêtres dit temporal donc il ya une
ouverture à l'arrière de l'oeil et cette
ouverture elle et c'était une insertion
musculaire et on pense à raison je crois
que c'est un caractère relativement
stable puisqu'il ya de tout très fortes
contraintes au niveau du développement
de cette de cette fausse temporal donc
les synapses id que sont les mammifères
ont que sont les mammifères modernes et
que dans lesquels on trouve les donc les
eaux fia comptons offrir condom et idées
qui sont des pays qu aux orres on y
trouve dit métro donc voilà il est ici
on y trouve aussi il était rapide donc
l'état rapides qui devraient se trouver
un peu plus loin normalement que dit
métro dont un peu plus au dessus dans le
permien sedan le permis un moyen est
supérieur mais voilà on est on y trouve
les mammifères bon tous et toutes ces
bestioles là elles ont une seule fausse
temporal en position basse
donc c'est la fausse temporal en
position basse c'est ce que je vais vous
montrer la voie là si vous regardez un
crâne qui a deux fosses temporal une
hotte une basse voilà les synapses in
donc que celle là donc ça ce sont des
craintes de synappci 10 n'ont qu'une
seule fausse temporal basse les reptiles
eux par contre c'est un peu plus
compliqué l'histoire donc l'histoire
avance est phylogénie c'était que les
reptiles
il avait un crâne annappes site
c'est-à-dire sans fausse temporal
primitivement puis ils ont développé
deux fosses temporal c'est ce qu'on
appelle le
à condition d'y abside mais il n'avait
dû - croyez ton il n'avait jamais
développé la condition intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire la condition synappci donc
les reptiles dans l'histoire qu'on
croyait avant ils passaient directement
de pas de fausse temporal à deux fosses
temporal donc anne apside dioxyde et
benson lui enfin benson et son équipe du
coup bah ui ils ont voulu tester cette
hypothèse en gros en faisant un codage
un peu particulier c'est à dire que ils
ont voulu ne pas contraindre finalement
les fausses temporal à avoir trop
d'importance dans leur fils au génie
donc c'est ce qu'ils expliquent ici
du coup ils n'ont pas coder les fausses
temporal voilà tout simplement
donc c'est ce qu'ils disent je crois
voilà ils ont ils ont codé dans leur
matrice de caractère donc dans l'eure
dans leur 294 caractère là ils ont codé
des caractères qui ont à voir avec la
morphologie du crâne avec avec la
participation d eau aux fenêtres
temporal etc mais ils n'ont pas coder
s'il y avait faute temporal oui ou non
voilà en gros est fausse temporal en
position basse fosse temporel en
position haute
de façon à ne pas contraindre en fait la
phylogénie à suivre la taxonomie la
taxonomie qui est couramment admise et
c'est comme ça qu'ils obtiennent cet
arbre au final donc les fausses temporal
sont indirectement codé puisqu'on code
quand même la façon dont les eaux sont
disposés dans le crâne ce qui est
directement dépendant de la présence ou
non de fausses temporal mais la présence
ou non des fausses temporal n'est pas
elle-même codée dans la matrice et c'est
comme ça qu'ils obtiennent ce résultat
est donc et bien on revienne à tort lui
la deux fosses temporal donc dans leur
matrice du moins il a il a deux fosses
temporal ce qui est quand même
alors ce qui est quand même douté un de
base hors venator donc je reviens
à l'image de robben a tort vous voyez
que c'est quand même en pointillés tout
ce petit monde a c'est quand même en
pointillés parce qu'en fait ils ont sur
le crâne ils ont la partie supérieure là
ils ont la partie inférieure est donc la
présence de deux fosses temporal elle
est plus hypothétique que réellement que
réellement préserver c'est pas si clair
que ça sur le fossile donc pour le coup
hors venator c'est lui qui a lancé
l'hypothèse de la possibilité que les
varane hop il est soit dit abside mais
c'est pas lui qui la soutient le mieux
les caractères d'ailleurs qui
soutiennent ces qui soutiennent la
position des varannes hop idée parmi les
les parmi les les
les reptiles ya sont très peu sont très
peu corrélés finalement à la morphologie
du crâne
d'après ce qu'ils disent dans l'article
dab donc donc finalement ça aurait pas
tant à voir avec la fausse temporal les
varano pidc vraiment des cdc décès des
reptiles malien donc des synapses ide
qui ressemble quand même vachement à des
reptiliens
et c'est marrant du coup parce que l'on
pensait du coup que c'était une
convergence en fait on pensait que
c'était juste des synapses ide qui avait
une seule fausse temporal et le reste du
crâne qui ressemblaient à des reptiliens
et en fait non ce que je propose c'est
que ils ce sont des ce sont des reptiles
pardon mais qui en fait ressemble
vachement à décines apside au niveau de
leur fosse temporal parce que hors
venator ok il ya peut-être un doute sur
le fait qu'il a peut-être une ou deux
phrases temporal mais par contre voilà
vannes varane up sont allés à des
spécimens magnifique
ils ont deux fosses temporal et les aux
eaux russes on en a des spécimens
articulé absolument formidable ils ont
une seule fausse temporal donc bref y'a
pas de doute sur le fait que les varano
pide ont une seule fausse temporal à
part peut-être hors venator donc
donc voilà le placement des varannes hop
idée parmi les reptiles ya là comme je
les dis c'est pas la première fois qu'il
sort et du coup ça commence
sachant que c'est une fille le génie qui
est quand même bien construite qui est
quand même
voilà qui va être dur à falsifier quoi
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
résultat qui va falloir prendre en
compte dans le futur
voilà la possibilité que les varane au
pid et que la possibilité même que les
synapses ide ne soit plus un groupe
monofil étiquetas vous imaginez c'est
quand même ça le truc c'est les synopsis
c'est quand même un groupe l'on n'y a
quasiment pas touché depuis qu'il a été
créé quoi ya ce qu'on a mis dans les
synapses hideux
à l'invention du mot synappci deçà n'en
n'a quasiment pas bougé un donc là pour
le coup c'est vraiment un gros gros
résultat gros gros gros résultat grosse
remise en question de ce qu'on croit
savoir de la phylogénie des amis hot et
du coup ça fout aussi la mère de haut
niveau du scénario de l'évolution des
fosses temporal parce que autrefois on
pensait donc que la condition basale
chez les amis note c'était la condition
and apside donc pas de fausse temporal
du coup si les varane au pid et se
déplacent et viennent se ficher là bas
ça change un tout du coup ça veut dire
que avant d'atteindre la condition d'y
abside ou à un moment dans l'évolution
de la condition des apps il ya eu une
condition sine abside donc c'est alors
c'est un peu ce que la figure suivante
explique voilà donc on à la condition
sine apside qui est en verre ici donc
c'est ce qu'on retrouve chez les
synapses id une seule fausse temporal
basse donc c'est ce qu'on voit lâché 10
métro dont ses classiques voilà et alors
chez les reptiliens on a d'abord une
condition and apside primitive puis
l'évolution de la condition d'y abside
chez les a réhaussé l'idée parce que non
ouais alors en plus c'est encore pire
que ça c'est encore pire que ça parce
que regarder
là vous avez les varane au pid et l'un
d'entre eux qui seraient peut-être dit
abside les autres sont synappci d' ici
mais avant eux
le noeud qui a juste avant ici petro la
cause aurait à réhausser lice ces deux
là là ce sont des dioxydes et avant ça
là ce sont des ânes apside donc on passe
d'abord par de la nappe side puis donc
c'est ce qui montre là on passe d'abord
par de la nappe side on saute à dudit
abside on revient à du synappci d' avec
les varane au pid et puis on repart sur
les paras reptiles qui certains ont une
condition sine apside c'est vrai ça me
lire et à emi l'air aux russes par
exemple iso inco dux une condition sine
apside mai au zoo russe a aussi une
condition sine apside mêlée parra
reptiles
globalement la plupart sont en abside
comme les pareil azor par exemple scuto
horus typiquement donc ça veut dire que
les paras reptiles aurait perdu la
condition sine abside et les varane au
pid et aurait perdu
la condition d'y abside et les ensuite
les néo dit abside aurait soit acquis de
nouveaux soit conservé la condition
dioxyde d arrêt au celi dont c'est pas
du goût donc cessé en face à sète
phylogénie elf ou un foutoir monstre
c'est un foutoir non négligeable l'a
donc donc ouais la condition and apside
apparemment il la conserve comme étant
primitive
ok c'est toujours un incident à la base
mais du coup on a évolution de la
condition d'y apside disparition de la
condition d'y abside disparition de la
condition siège ce dioxyde oubien
conservation de la condition d'y abside
jusqu'en et au dioxyde avec perte double
enfin c'est waouh
voilà ça complique énormément la faire
et là là il va y avoir du boulot comme
j'ai dit là on en a pour dix ans on en a
pour facile 10 ans à démêler ce à
démêler cette histoire quoi il va
falloir maintenant va falloir considérer
qu'il est possible qu'on se soit planté
depuis le début et que les barres and
hope i des crs et une c'est un peu c'est
un peu comme l'hypothèse des ornithos
élida pour les dinosaures sauf que là ça
touche non seulement ça touche pas que
les gens qui étudient et dinosaures là
ça touche les gens qui étudient les
paras reptiles ça a été ça touche les
gens qui étudient les reptiles sayah
touche les gens qui étudient les
synapses id voilà ça touche absolument
tous les gens qui font du vertébrés qui
ne sont ni de l'amphi bhl qui ne sont
pas de l'amphibien ou du poisson
en gros tous les gens qui étudient les
vertébrés qui ne sont pas de l'amphibian
du poisson sont affectés par cette
nouvelle phylogénie donc c'est
absolument
enfin je vais pas dire que c'est une
catastrophe mais mais ouais c'est
carrément monstrueux quoi est ce qui
vient de se produire
donc on verra bien ce que le futur
réserve à cette phylogénie si elle sera
confirmée ou infirmée
si on va trouver d'autres caractères qui
vont dans le même sens ou non mais voilà
c'est intéressant comme résultat est un
des développements futurs qu'il va
falloir surveiller ses menottes aux
russes parce que une auto russe
il est
il fait partie des choses qu'on
rapproche finalement des kélonia c'est à
dire des tortues mais n'autorise s'il
est classiquement inclus dans les paras
reptiles donc ça a toujours été un truc
très très litigieux n'autorise parce que
si c'est une tortue 6-1 au taurus est
bel et bien à kélonia et cliquer le lien
sont bel et bien les proches parents des
archosaures au mof comme l'indiquent les
données génétiques n'autorise devrait se
brancher la du côté de pro la serta et
protérozoïque us mais si on autorise cet
apparat reptiles alors ils devaient se
brancher la du côté de ces bestioles la
voilà donc donc à l'inclusion futur de
nos taurus ça va être un caractère
critique et papou kelis aussi papou
kelis hélas hélas le kélonia avec deux
fosses temporal donc le kélonia qui n'a
pas un crâne à la piscine mais qui
justement un crâne dit apside donc là
pour le coup papou kelis n'a pas été
inclus dans cette analyse ce que je
trouve assez assez bizarre parce que ça
aurait ce serait certainement aller dans
leur sens parce que dans l'or dans leurs
phylogénie il inclut quand même les
paras reptiles parmi les néo reptiles ya
donc on a déjà les paras reptiles qui
sont qui sont polis fils éthiques
enfin pardon par affi les tic puisque
vous voyez que les par les capteurs une
idée qui sont généralement inclus dans
les paras reptiles sont en sont exclus
donc déjà les paras reptiles son sein
parent a filé ticket vous avez d'autres
annappes seed com il aux normes us et
paléo thirith ici qui ne sont pas non
plus inclus dans les paras reptiles donc
déjà ça c'est une chose les paras
reptiles ne sont pas ne sont pas un mono
fils éthiques
d'ailleurs ils sont plus que par
affinity qui sont même poliphile éthique
pour le coup puisque là il n'y a pas de
pas de branchement direct entre entre
les caps torigni délai paraît petit live
vous voyez qu'il ya beaucoup de branches
entre les deux donc c'est même poliphile
éthique et mais du coup ça mais n'est
pas un reptile à côté des dioxydes et ça
c'est très intéressant parce que du coup
si pape o'kelly c'est une auto russe se
branchent parmi les paras reptiles ici
vous avez quand même
les tortues qui font partie des dix
abside alors que les tortues c'est
l'exemple le plus classique de d'espèces
en abside et en fait on sait que cette
condition en abside elle est que
secondaire mans acquise donc voilà il ya
tellement de choses il ya tellement
d'application à cette phylogénie jeu
j'ai j'espère avoir réussi à l'expliquer
de façon confuse mais c'est quasiment
impossible parce que ça change tout si
cette phylogénie est vrai je change tout
donc voilà c'est il va falloir attendre
les développements plus futur
l'inclusion de notes aux russes
regardent et d'autres caractères voir si
d'autres gens peuvent répéter cette
phylogénie et voir et voir s'il retrouve
le même résultat aussi s'il reconnaît
les caractères à leur façon et c'est
exactement comme ce qui s'est passé pour
les ornithos élida quoi voir voir si
quelqu'un voir si ça tient la route sur
le long terme quoi voilà ça c'est du
lourd et ça c'est complètement passé
sous le radar parce que c'est ça a été
publié le 23 décembre
donc évidemment quand tu publies ça une
veille de réveillon
ça passe complètement sous le radar
évidemment évidemment que ça passe
complètement sous le radar alors là ils
mettent janvier il se rattrape
il se rattrape ce sera publié sur papier
en janvier mais ça a été publié en ligne
le 24 23 décembre donc eh ben et ben
voilà
personne n'a vu personne n'a vu dommage
mais voilà merci nature écologie en
évolution merci les éditeurs de nature
écologie et d'évolution d'avoir choisi
cette date
bravo pareil même destin sortie le 30
décembre sortie une veille de réveillon
voilà la date est ici 30 décembre sortie
d'une veille de réveillon un magnifique
article sur tiktaalik on retrouve
évidemment nil chauvine ninja been qui
est le découvreur de tiktaalik qui a
conduit toutes les recherches sur
tiktaalik depuis sa découverte
donc ça fait maintenant presque 15 ans
donc magnifique article sur les sur les
membres de tiktaalik ou là ils se sont
focalisés sur les
les rayons l'évolution des rayons alors
les conclusions de l'article sont pas
fille folle c'est du banc c'est du
classique quoi tiktaalik avait des
rayons comme un poisson et des membres
comme invertébrés terrestres en gros
pour dire les choses simplement
c'est pas tiktaalik ce sas et le sténopé
theron il est où tiktaalik séoul images
avec tiktaalik stand theron en troll
voilà tiktaalik donc voilà ça c'est le
fossile de tiktaalik ça aussi
normalement voilà tiktaalik rosa et
c'est lui donc tiktaalik avait des
rayons comme un
comme un poisson et il avait un membre
un membre qui ressemblait à celui d'un
tétrapodes un peu organisés à la façon
de celui d'un indice 9 mai avec une
asymétrie en plus et il insiste beaucoup
sur la symétrie en fait la symétrie ça
montre que le développement de du bras
et de la jambe de tiktaalik était plus
proche de celle des tétrapodes terrestre
que de celle des du coelacanthe par
exemple donc parce que la symétrie en
fait c'est le premier truc qui va créer
en fait cette asymétrie de l'asymétrie
de développement du bras en fait c'est
ce qui va créer le fait qu' on a un os 2
os est plein dos après donc humérus
radio sud n'a et ensuite les eaux les
eaux du carpe ou bien le fémur tibia
fibula et les os du tarse donc c'est
cette asymétrie elle est très très
importante même si elle a l'air de rien
et même si superficiellement ça
ressemble plus à une nageoire de ces
lacs en tout 2 ou 2,10 meneust qu'à une
main ou un pied de tétrapodes en réalité
le cette asymétrie du développement est
critique dans l'évolution des tétrapodes
donc ça et il insiste beaucoup sur la
symétrie est en fait les ils ont trouvé
que même les rayons et est asymétrique
aussi ce qui n'est pas le cas par
exemple ce qui n'est pas complètement le
cas vous voyez chez cette magnifique
image du d'indy meneust donc voilà c'est
donc c'est une étude elle enfonce un peu
des portes ouvertes faut bien dire ce
qui est mais elle produit des images
uniques
voilà des images en 3d des membres de
tiktaalik donc voilà si vous êtes
enseignant c'est que du bon quoi c'est
du caviar pour les yeux et et c'est du
beau matos à montrer à vos étudiants
quoi c'est vraiment très très bien fait
et
et puis ça confirme des choses qu'on
s'attendait déjà à voir voilà et c'est
publié dans pays n et s est ensuite un
petit peu d'évolution humaine un petit
peu d'évolution humaine évidemment on ne
passe pas à côté de l'évolution humaine
un article publié par donc lyn wadleigh
lucinda blackwell et le
le chercheur basé en france francisco
d'eriko donc un petit peu de cocorico
dans cette dans cette publication
celle de la découverte donc d'un rhizome
c'est à dire d'une racine qui a été qui
a été cuisiné donc voilà une patate une
patate 270 mille ans et pas une patate
je sais plus je sais plus quel nom
commun de la plante
voilà c'est ça donc ça ressemble quand
même un peu à une patate et en gros
voilà c'est plein de c'est plein de
sucres lents c'est plein de d'amidon et
ça montre du coup que nos ancêtres d'il
ya cent soixante dix mille ans en
afrique du sud il cuisinait des cuisines
et des sucres lents
voilà donc c'est un peu c'est un peu le
1 doit bien levé bien haut au régime
paléo non évidemment je plaisante
évidemment je plaisante
c'est quand même intéressant de voir que
donc au paléolithique
voilà il ya 170 millions ou rendez
compte
homo sapiens sous sa forme
anatomiquement moderne apparaît il ya
deux cent mille ans et il ya trois cent
mille ans et la forme anatomiquement
archaïque un donc sous sa forme
anatomiquement moderne l'homo sapiens il
apparaît ya deux cent mille ans donc là
ça fait que 30 millions qu'homo sapiens
est là et il est déjà en train de
cultiver des rhizomes quoi il est déjà
en train de cultiver des pommes de terre
le truc c'est pas si vous vous rendez
compte de là c'est de la folie
et donc là il ya toute une hypothèse
justement sur comment homo sapiens
comment la dispersion d'homo sapiens a
littéralement suivent-ils la répartition
de ses rhizomes parce que les premiers
restes d'homo sapiens sedanais
anatomiquement modernes d'il ya deux
cent mille ans justement dans les trous
vous on les trouve en afrique du sud
on les trouve en afrique de l'est et on
en trouve un petit peu de plus en plus
justement dans le sud de la péninsule
arabique
donc ça suis quand même complètement la
dispersion la répartition de ces fameux
reason donc c'est angus tifo liane je ne
sais plus quelle espèce le nom du genre
hypoxie voilà hypoxie angustifolia et
donc ça ça a quand même deux
implications majeures les deux
applications majeures de
de cette découverte c'est d'une main que
déjà la distribution d' homo sapiens
l'air de répartition d'homo sapiens elle
est intimement liée à une plante et ça
c'est quand même cool
enfin je veux dire si c'est encore une
fois c'est une hypothèse l'hypothèse
c'est que peut-être la répartition
d'homo sapiens était beaucoup plus liées
à la répartition des ressources qu'on ne
l'imaginé et notamment à une répartie à
la répartition d'une ressource avec elle
on s'attendait pas à savoir
ddd rhizome riches en sucres lents
plutôt que du gibier ou plutôt que des
baies ou des fruits ou des trucs comme
ça là pour le coup c'est un type de
nourriture auquel on s'attendait pas
donc déjà on voit cette très forte
corrélation qui suggère une causalité
voilà en gros et ça ça va être à
vérifier dans le futur mais surtout la
deuxième la deuxième
chose importante que cette étude suggère
c'est un truc sur l'origine de
l'agriculture parce que si la
répartition d'homo sapiens suis
réellement la distribution de ses
rhizomes et qu'on sait qu'ils étaient
capables de l'est que de les reconnaître
de l'école de les cueillir et de les
cuisiner ça c'est enfin je veux dire
c'est déjà un tremplin vers
l'agriculture c'est à dire que voilà il
ya déjà il ya déjà cette idée dans la
tête des homo sapiens d'il ya cent
soixante dix mille ans de récolter des
rhizomes comme on récolte aujourd'hui
les des pommes de terre quoi donc c'est
ou d'auto ou des carottes ou je sais pas
quoi c'est voilà c'est la naissance déjà
de base de l'agriculture même si en
l'occurrence il ne devait probablement
pas les semer etc
il devait quand même surveiller déjà où
étaient ses rhizomes où les trouver
surveiller quand est-ce qu'il était le
mieux pour les récolter et je veux dire
c'est pas un fruit faut soulever il faut
savoir faut connaître à quelle saison le
rhizome va être plus gros le est le
mieux pour être pour être récoltés parce
que ça se voie pas vu de l'extérieur
justement le rhizome il est enterré
donc voilà ça ça ça énormément
d'implication sur l'origine de
l'agriculture et peut-être que l'origine
de l'agriculture elle n'est pas enfin je
veux dire c'est peut-être pas un
événement aussi aussi soudain que peut
être que dans un futur proche on
découvrira que ce n'est peut-être pas un
événement aussi soudain que ça l'origine
de l'agriculture peut-être que ça a été
un événement très lent et avec des
petites améliorations finalement de de
la cueillette et que finalement cette
cueillette on l'a rendue régulière on
l'a rendue systématique petit à petit et
c'est donc voilà et c'est cette étude
c'est possiblement le premier pas vers
cette découverte l'a donc voilà à
surveiller à surveiller intensément et
justement quand on attend d'eux
d'implication sur l'évolution d'homo
sapiens on se dit presque voilà le nano
c'est presque dommage qu'on ait préféré
nano tyrannus à ce à quoi voilà parce
que là il ya clairement il ya clairement
des implications qui sont gigantesques
sur 7
sur cette découverte donc à suivre à
suivre de très près maintenant on
continue sur une note un peu plus
légères on va continuer et que sur des
notes un peu plus légères voilà des
choses plutôt marrante
on va dire que que avec des implications
scientifique gigantesque la première
c'est donc mégalo acné chailly shohei
shaoyang nsync voilà si vous n'êtes pas
chinois je pense que c'est très
difficile à prononcer mégalo arachne
mégalo arachne oui c'est ça shaoyang n 6
du crétacé de la formation lingang en
chine n'est pas une araignée mais en
fait est un cri affiche donc c'est un
une écrevisse
donc voilà ça donc voilà le fossile donc
voilà le fossile qui a été originalement
interprétée comme une araignée je veux
dire on a quand même on est quand même
d'accord sur le fait que ça ressemble
vachement une araignée voilà il ya huit
pattes ya un abdomen ya un céphalothorax
mais par contre ce qui a mis la puce à
l'oreille de nos deux des auteurs de cet
article en fait c'est les yeux regardez
la taille des yeux voilà le truc qu'il a
des yeux gigantesque et pédonculé quoi
donc ça ça leur a mis la puce à
l'oreille et en fait ils ont vérifié le
fossile et se sont rendu compte en le
passant à une la lumière alors une
lumière spéciale qui est qui et la
fluorescence vola par microscopie à
fluorescence voilà ils se sont rendus
compte qu'en fait toutes ces parties là
vous voyez c'était des partis qui
étaient peintes en fait qu'ils étaient
pattes par dessus le fossile donc ce
qu'en fait ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on peut réellement
voir sur le fossile c'est ce que le
fossile préserverez allemand est en fait
ils ont peint de là vous avez les pinces
en fait qui était cassé donc on voit pas
les pinces mais on voit juste les
appendices qui porte les pinces mais en
fait ils ont peint des îles ont pas des
pâtes à la place de l'endroit où il y
avait les passes et ils ont rajouté 2
grosse paire de pattes voyez à l'arrière
qui était aussi complètement pinte
donc voilà c'est donc en fait c'était un
faux c'était totalement info ce mégalo
arachne mais ça s'arrête mongole arachne
pardon d'ailleurs depuis tout à l'heure
je dis mégalo mais c'est mon goal
arachne et dans ce manga laraque n'est
en fait c'est juste une face et pas
juste une écrevisse c'est toujours
intéressant mais du met ces voix là on
peut se faire avoir des fois mais par
contre alors ça déjà ça montre une chose
c'est que ces fossiles chinois fu faut
s'en méfier
n'est ce pas alsc à raptor 1 2 les trucs
qui viennent de chine de mongolie tout
ça qu'ils sont pas très nette qui sont
passés par des réseaux un peu bizarre
faut s'en méfier
non
ils sont souvent remaniée voilà c'était
déjà arrivé avec l'arc et aux raptor qui
est d'ailleurs cité un dance est dans
cette étude
donc voilà est ce qu'il ya de ski a
justement est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
aussi c'est que m'a évidemment ça va ça
peut donner du grain à moudre aux
créationnistes mais en fait je pense pas
évidemment il va y avoir un effet pile
d'arn les gens ils vont dire vous voyez
il fabrique des faux cils ses défauts
les fossiles ça n'existe pas il ne
montre pas l'évolution mais non mais non
l'homme de pilsen voyait on a mis 50 ans
pour reconnaître que c'était un faux
l'archéo raptor voilà ça la supercherie
a été reconnu en 2001 alors que
l'article original il était de 99 donc
seulement deux ans après est bien celui
là
voyez c'est un mongole arachne chat yang
n 6 elle a été décrite pour la première
fois en 2019 et la même année vous avez
déjà un article qui dit non en fait
cette info voilà donc et à chaque fois
un que ce soit pile demande ou archéo
raptor ou mais mungo laraque ne sait
jamais les créationnistes qui ont pointé
du doigt le fait que c'était des faux
seins c'est toujours les scientifiques
donc faut pas perdre de vue aussi le
fait que voilà bon la science est un
processus auto correctifs et ça implique
que de temps en temps il ya des erreurs
qui sont commises
voilà donc mongole arachne c'était une
erreur enfin schengen sis à les autres
espèces de montgueux laraque n'est pour
l'instant elles sont pas remises en
question mais voilà mongole arachne
shouyang m6 c'était une erreur et la
science auto correctives a bien fait son
boulot et ça confirme ce que je n'arrête
pas de dire sur le fait que la
le processus de peer review ne s'arrête
pas à la publication 1 les publications
rende publiques les découvertes
justement pour qu'elle soit lue par
d'autres perd plus de pères plus de
spécialistes et qu'elle soit valider ou
rejeter voilà donc mongole arachne c'est
peut-être un faux mais c'est un faux qui
a été très vite détectés et qui aura
donc très peu d'incidence sur notre
compréhension de l'évolution de cette de
ce genre d'araignée du crétacé voilà
donc pas de soucis mais voilà c'est une
petite c'est un petit fun fact et puis
c'est marrant c'est marrant de voir en
fait qu'il ya des erreurs des fois aussi
qui sont commises mais c'est pas grave
c'est le jeu ma pauvre lucette
c'est le jeu et puis bah un petit peu
d'auto promotion quand même voilà notre
article sur les thérapies site du caroux
est sorti dans la revue fossiles voilà
donc vous pouvez voir la couverture ici
donc si vous si vous voyez le si vous le
voyez en kiosque et ben je t'ai dit un
coup d'oeil voyez qu'en plus on est même
sur la couverture voilà les thérapies
des autres fossiles du caroux c'est un
joli petit article qu'on a écrit avec
donc aliénor duhamel qui a été ma
collaboratrice sur le projet trine axe
et sophie brard qui est ma
collaboratrice sur la chaîne entracte
science et puis bon on y parle
au début on y parle un peu de notre
petite vie à johannesbourg et puis de
comment cette vie à johannesbourg et
rythmée par les fossiles les fossiles
qu'on trouve pas loin de johannesburg
cradle of humankind et les fossiles
qu'on trouve un peu plus loin dans le
carreau donc voilà il ya des jolies
photos on a essayé de faire un texte un
peu sympa s'est expliqué ce à la façon
un peu d'un road trip à travers le
caroux et à travers les ères géologiques
donc voilà c'est vous aussi ça vous
intéresse allez-y ça résume presque ça
résume peu ou prou ce qu'on a fait faire
à cédric au final on l'a fait faire un
bon road trip à travers le caroux
fossilifère voilà est d'ailleurs
puisqu'on parle du projet trine axe
voilà projet trine axe qui va qui est
qui atteint finalement la presse sud
africaine
voilà donc les studios les étudiants et
les rangers qui trouvent des fossiles
dans l'hystérie kate donc à ovi stone
c'est là où nous sommes allés voilà
c'est un des crânes d'oeufs de liste
rose aux russes qu'on a découvert à ovi
stone voici la photo de la réserve de
vie stone où nous nous trouvions donc
voilà c'est un article qui parle de nos
fossiles bon c'est normal c'est moi qui
les ai écrits et donc on a réussi à
faire parler de nous quand même dans la
presse locale
donc voilà le projet trina qui se prend
son envol et atteint les hautes sphères
de la presse bon ok c'est la presse
locale je sais mais voilà c'est c'est
pour montrer que quand même il ya des
petites retombées directes déjà et que
voilà ça intéresse les gens
voilà ça c'était une grande première et
tout ça ça a été possible grâce au
projet trine axe merci encore à tous
voila voila c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]